amber heard reveals some surprising
post-trial feelings towards ex johnny
depp
i love him i loved him with all my heart
haley bieber updates fans on justin's
rare condition can't smile on this side
of my face he is getting better every
single day and brad pitt still loves
gweneth paltrow plus rayne wilson
reflects on the upcoming 10-year
anniversary of the office
i think about the office a lot because
it's become so culturally iconic you put
my stuff in jello again et's the
download starts right now
[Music]
we begin with a bold and unexpected
admission from amber heard about her ex
johnny depp i love him
i loved him with all my heart
and i tried the best i could to make a
deeply broken relationship work
and
i couldn't
i
have no bad feelings or ill will towards
him at all
in an interview with today heard
confessed that she still cares for her
ex-husband even after claiming that he
was abusive in their marriage it's god
did he just hit me
i knew there was no i knew it was
wrong and i knew that i had to leave him
i'm not
a good victim i get it i'm not a likable
victim i'm not a perfect victim
but
i
when i testified i asked the jury to
just see me
as human and hear
his own words she was quite violent
and she was quite cruel
the battle of the exes ended with a
six-week trial and the jury found that
heard defamed depp the trial seemed to
prove that sometimes heartbreak does
come with a price tag she was ordered to
pay debt more than 10 million dollars in
damages do you feel like you could be
sued again by him for defamation i'm
scared
that
no matter what i do
no matter what i say or how i say it
um every step that i take
will present another opportunity
for
this sort of uh silencing
which is what i guess a defamation
lawsuit is meant to do it's meant to
take your voice how do you see your
future now
i get to be a mom full-time you know
where i'm not having to juggle
calls
with lawyers i don't think we're going
to see yet another defamation suit
brought on by johnny depp and his team
number one amber heard has already
indicated she can't pay for the
defamation verdict she already lost and
more importantly i think johnny depp
recognizes the jury has spoken in his
favor and the court of public opinion
supports him regardless of what she says
after the verdict
well over on good morning america haley
bieber is given an update on husband
justin bieber after his ramsay hunt
syndrome diagnosis
he's doing really well he is getting
better every single day
he's feeling a lot better and obviously
was just a very
scary and random situation to happen
late last week the singer shared his
diagnosis on social media revealing his
health struggles left half his face
paralyzed this is pretty serious as you
can see i'm gonna get better and i'm
doing all these facial exercises to
get my face back to
normal
justin shared on instagram monday he's
been leaning on his faith and while on
gma haley says he's also leaning on her
and i think the silver lining of it
honestly is that it brings us a lot
closer because you're going through this
together you're being there for each
other you're supporting each other and
there's just
something that really like bonds you
through through these times
haley has also dealt with her own health
issues this year back in march she
suffered a mini stroke and underwent
open heart surgery it was a little hard
for me to recover from the procedure
just giving myself the time to be able
to like work out again and feel like
normal if that makes sense but i'm doing
well now and you know i'm not having to
be on any medication anymore so
i feel good meanwhile britney spears is
going off on instagram revealing to fans
that her brother brian was not invited
to her wedding in a since deleted post
brit said you honestly think i want my
brother there who told me no to a jack
and coke for four years she goes on to
say you hurt me and you know it last
week her brother was reportedly on the
guest list for brit and sam eskari's
nuptials but in a comment on instagram
brian's girlfriend said he didn't attend
because his 11 year old daughter's fifth
grade graduation was the same day quote
we couldn't help the timings brian felt
terrible having to choose as we know
brittany's mom lynne and her sister
jamie lynn were also not invited
brittany ended her rant with this i know
you're my blood and yes blood runs deep
but no family of mine would do what you
guys did to me now those aren't the only
people the singer is cutting ties with
britney has also reportedly fired her
security team after her ex-husband jason
alexander broke into her home on her
wedding day she's my first wife my only
wife i'm her first husband i'm here to
crash the wedding
[Music]
oh is harry styles ready for a one
direction reunion
crying it'll be overnight
he just sold the spout podcast it's not
out of the question i think the thought
of it is is a really nice one i think
you know i'd love for that to be a time
where it felt like something we all
wanted to do there's a lot of love there
so
um yeah i think i think if there's a
moment for us to do it the right way i
think it'd be great
since going solo harry has also become
an actor and today we are getting our
first look at his performance in my
policeman premiering on october 21st so
how does it make you feel
you feel they could crush you
it explores forbidden love harry playing
a married closeted police officer who
develops a secret relationship
you just have to let it take hold of you
but harry is of course out here living
out loud with olivia wilde the two were
recently spotted in london sharing some
sweet pda as he kicks off the european
leg of his new world tour tonight
now on to gwyneth paltrow 25 years after
she and brad pitt yes remember when they
were together called off their
engagement they've got nothing but love
for each other don't worry gwen is still
happily married to another brad brad
falchuk she just thinks mr pitt makes a
better bestie than boo gwyneth
interviews her ex on her goop blog and
they ended the convo with gwyneth saying
i finally found the brat i was supposed
to marry it just took me 20 years he
replies and it's lovely to have you as a
friend now gwen says it is brad
continues the love mess with and i do
love you and i'm sorry this has been so
mind-boggled so then gwen responds i
love you so much i need you you're brad
i'm i'm going right now i live for it i
love the friendliness that they gave us
some back in the day vibe so we found
this gem from 1996 when they announced
their engagement right here on et yes i
got engaged how did you propose to
question i'm not going to tell you that
i would never tell you that that's one
of the greatest moments of my life
beamy and goofy i take um
the institution of marriage extremely
seriously everybody there are no
divorces in my family and
um
and then his um either so
this is not something that you know this
you know we've been together for quite
some time so it was this is not a rash
decision
but they did split in 1997 but have
obviously remained friends which you
know seems to be a common theme for brad
in 2020 he was spotted holding hands
with his former misses jennifer aniston
at the sag awards and during the
pandemic they did a flirty table read of
fast times at ridgemont high together to
raise money for charity hi aniston hi
pitt how you doing good honey how are
you doing i'm all right
everyone's freaking out every time all
the feels speaking of all the feels
katie holmes knows all about bouncing
back after a breakup too and the look
she has given her musician boy from
bobby wooten says it all she is in love
they couldn't keep their hands off each
other at the alone together premiere
last night at the tribeca film festival
a source tells e.t they've been dating
for a few months and are quote perfectly
matched this is the second time we've
actually seen them together a few weeks
ago they made it red carpet official at
the mothball gala in nyc
and now to breakups jason momoa and aza
gonzalez have called it quits we first
got word that they were casually dating
last month but now work is getting in
the way source tells et that jason and
asa are both too busy and jason is very
focused on his career right now and they
just realize they're different and
looking for different things aza is the
first woman jason has been linked to
since his split from lisa bonnet they
were together for 16 years and announced
their divorce back in january the source
told us at the time they were committed
to being friends for the sake of their
family what's been the best thing about
being married next
level next level
well it looks like keenan thompson is
headed toward the single life too two
months after his report is split from
his wife of 11 years tmz says today he's
officially filed divorce papers adding
the two are in the process of sorting
out custody of their two daughters e.t
has reached out for comment meanwhile
keenan's staying busy with work as the
longest tenured cast member on snl he's
telling us exclusively about his plans
to stay on the iconic show what keeps me
coming back is them asking me to come
back you know what i'm saying like we're
at least trying to get to the 50th
because that's going to be a special
year you know what i mean and then
after that it's like i don't know
exactly how long i can do it
you know ryan gosling has hosted snl
twice but today he is showing off his
tanned abs bleach blonde hair and
monogrammed underwear as ken in this
first look photo from greta gerwig's
barbie also co-starring margot robbie
the movie coming to theaters next summer
co-stars shang chi himself simu liu who
is rumored to start as another ken he
told us he couldn't keep up with ryan in
the gym i loved your tik-tok when you're
like i gotta work out cause i'm in a
movie with ryan gosling
who worked out harder oh definitely ryan
i'm gonna 100
as much as i i believe that i do have a
work ethic i also
love
food
a lot what can we expect from the movie
um i feel like the less i tell you the
better because i feel like every little
piece of news that comes out to tease
people everyone just gets progressively
more confused and curious and i kind of
like that well from one doll to another
buzz lightyear and fun fact did you know
that chris evans who is the new voice of
buzz celebrated his 41st birthday this
week and shares a birthday with the o.g
tim allen chris tells et's
i mean synergy look at that chris tells
et's matt cohen he's grateful to be
adding his voice to light year's legacy
ready captain lightyear ready as i'll
ever be commander hawthorne this was
actually pretty intimidating you know
because obviously tim allen is buzz
lightyear yeah and that it's tough to
try and fill those shoes i'm using what
he did right as a blueprint he is buzz
lightyear will always be blessed to
infinity and beyond
i want to talk about socks for a second
this robot cat that everybody's chatting
about i know you're a dog guy how would
dodger get on with socks god oh with
socks he'd be great he's great but i've
always debated i mean dodger loves
playing with dogs but the few times in
my life if i've you know dog sat for
another dog when it comes time for bed
and the dogs crawl into bed all of a
sudden dodger becomes a little like you
know okay who the hell are you and
get out of here also teaming up with
buzz in this space mission uzo aduba has
his longtime commander and kiki palmer
as a space ranger in training if we
could explore any other character in the
toy story universe is there any anybody
you would like to explore
i would love to see woody's
story i'm curious about the mr potato
head he's got a thing as for chris's
next project he's starring alongside
anna de armas and ryan gosling in the
gray man netflix's most expensive movie
ever
you must be loyal we'll give it away the
trash stash well obviously there's the
mustache
gift okay please i'm very happy with the
chris evans mustache yeah it's really
fun it's fun to play a villain it's fun
to play opposite someone is
as
talented and magnetic as ryan i'm really
excited for that one
now chris who also started knives out
won't be in the sequel but here's
everything we know about the upcoming
murder mystery new this week an official
title it's called glass onion a knives
out mystery no release date yet but
netflix promises we'll be able to watch
it this holiday season daniel craig is
back to crack his next case as benoit
blanc and will be introduced to a new
cast of colorful suspects including
leslie odom jr catherine hahn janelle
monae and kate hudson what can you tell
us you know what nothing nothing
all i can say is i feel very honored to
be a part of it it's uh it's going to be
great it's going to be very different
and yeah just a wonderful wonderful
thing to shoot yeah suspect everyone is
what i can tell you did you do it
we're also learning more about the
hunger games prequel in today's world
meet the new mentors and tributes lots
of newcomers including jerome lance
mackenzie lansing knox gibson amer
hussein and ashley liao so they joined
lead rachel zegler alongside tom blythe
who's actually playing a young president
snow the ballot of songbirds and snakes
hits theaters november 17 2023
from hunger games to squid game soon if
you're brave enough you'll be able to
play in real life
netflix is currently casting more than
450 people for squid game the challenge
a competition series that brings the
dark dystopian series to life it'll be
the biggest reality cast ever competing
for the biggest cash prize in tv history
4.56 million dollars you can enter now
at squidgamecasting.com
cash i go for it listen i don't want to
lose a day of you here but if you're out
there getting that money six million
dollars i'm not going to scream
thank you
now we don't know which schoolyard games
will be adapted for the challenge but we
do know a second season of squid game
the series is coming when it was
released last fall it quickly became
netflix's most popular show of all time
all right now to a viral salad scandal
you heard it right after rachel green's
greens sparked a social media frenzy
jennifer aniston is daring to debunk the
tick tock trend jennifer anderson ate
the salad on the set of friends for 10
years and i can see why
back in 2010 courtney cox told the la
times aniston devoured a doctored up cob
on the set of friends every day for 10
years it quickly became a social media
staple with countless friends fans
taking their stab at the recipe but jen
is now setting the record straight so in
an interview with elle she confesses
it's not the salad she ate every day
saying i would never have that much
chickpea in a salad to be honest not
good for the digestive tract
the more you know jen did say the salad
looks delicious though for what it's
worth there you have it well another
famous friend is ready to dish matthew
perry says his memoir is complete perry
posted a snap of the title friends
lovers and the big terrible thing on
instagram the tell-all will feature
stories from his time on friends and
shed a light on his past personal
struggles the book is set for release in
november speaking of iconic shows it has
been nearly 10 years since the office
ended e.t caught up with rayne wilson
who's starring in jerry and marge go
large out friday on paramount plus he
reflected on his time as dwight a role
that became even more timeless since the
series hit streaming
i think about the office a lot because
it's become so culturally
iconic
you know obviously i'm recognized all
the time and i'm just so grateful but
the fact that we were able to make
something that still resonates
especially with young people today
um
is is really miraculous identity theft
is not a joke jim
millions of families suffer every year
michael
oh that's funny michael
meantime sitcom queen leah remini is
making her judging debut tonight on so
you think he can dance as the series
celebrates 300 episodes she's of course
replacing matthew morrison and i had a
chance to ask if she's consulted her
bestie your girl j.lo she obviously was
a judge on a dance competition show as
well did you reach out for any advice
did you need advice
like you know
no it was easy yes no i would call her
and say i have some notes she was like
don't send me because i don't care what
you think
what was your reaction when you got that
call yeah makes sense why wouldn't i be
judging yeah i mean it does make sense
to you because i love dancing i love
dancers i love dance shows
how do you feel about leah into the mix
now she's hilarious she's amazing she is
an artist she offers honesty like you
know what i mean there's there's nothing
wrong with somebody being like hey i
don't know the technical aspects of this
but i can tell you how i felt as a
fellow artist and that's what we're
looking for
jojo siwa's former dance moms co-star
maddie ziegler covers cosmo this month
and in it she explains why she cut off
their former coach abby lee miller i'm
so grateful for the show because it got
me to where i am today and uh it's
helped me you know with so many
opportunities
grateful for dance moms but maddie is
okay with leaving one part in the past
they distanced themselves all of them
all the kids all the moms
act as if
i had nothing to do with the show nor my
studio she reveals she hasn't spoken to
abby since she and her sister kenzie
left the lifetime show and abby's dance
company in 2016. we need to get into the
groove and you need to be my number one
girl out there every week again do you
understand that yes maddie says she
trained me she helped me but also i knew
i would be okay without her and i was
sick of being in a toxic environment i
was like this is not for me i can't do
this
the dancer turned actress initially felt
guilty for leaving and was distraught
but now maddie says she's at peace i'm
just happy
now there is one dance mom star who will
always show love to abby jojo siwa i
will always remember where i came from
abby actually taught me a lot you know
abby has a lot of dance knowledge and
and i i carry a lot of what she taught
me with me
now to more young adults the cast of the
summer i turn pretty coming to prime
video friday the series based on one of
author jenny han's new york times
bestsellers features some acting
newcomers but one very familiar voice on
the soundtrack
[Music]
yes that is taylor swift who took to
instagram to thank jenny for debuting
her version of this love in the trailer
adding i've always been so proud of this
song and i'm very emotional face emoji
about this turn of events and you know
what so is jenny and series lee lola
tong who i had a chance to chat with i
have been a fan of taylor swift for so
many years and was even writing these
books to her music
um and did i tell you this i was going
to like dedicate the second book to her
really yes and then i did it i'm like is
that i was like is that weird because
she doesn't know me then i would
dedicate a book to her but that's how
much
um her music
really meant to me into the story it
just feels like really
incredible meant to be yeah magical yeah
um
because i can't think of another artist
that really matches up as well to
the story now from taylor to mickey
guyton only e.t has taken you behind the
scenes of her special cmt event with the
black pumas and dakota johnson tells us
what it's really like becoming a meme
how was the party i wasn't invited
actually no that's not the truth ellen
you were invited to me it's just
bizarre
et's the download will be right back
[Music]
keeping up with country only e.t was
invited to the set of cmt crossroads
black pumas and mickey guyton which airs
tonight on cmt
[Applause]
it's just so cool that we get to do cmt
crossroads together my husband loves the
black pumas and you know listening to
their music they're genreless and
they're just
truly incredible artists
[Music]
we're both very very honored to be here
i think you know sparks fly when when
people like that get together
[Music]
other than black pumas mickey's also got
her eye on a few other artists she'd
like to make some music with soon i just
found out that monica is doing a country
album so i would love to do something
with her dolly barton
she's someone that is just a dream that
i would just be so honored to do
something with her i would love to
do something with carrie and marin
while we wait for those major moments
here's another one dakota johnson
reacting to becoming a meme the actress
stars in cha cha real smooth coming
friday to apple tv plus here she is with
et's lauren zima you have become known
as like the beloved queen of viral memes
on the internet oh my god i'm not aware
of them you turned 30. i did and um how
was the party i wasn't invited
actually no that's not the truth ellen
you were invited last year no last time
i was on the show
last year you gave me a bunch about not
inviting you actually the other day
spike jones sent me a picture of um
a woman who works with him wearing a
t-shirt of something i said with a
drawing of me on it
i was like what that's wild do you just
laugh about it yeah because i don't i'm
not really on social media i don't i
don't see these things so to me it's
just
bizarre
sorry
i mean that meme is a piece of internet
and tv history iconic also i don't
believe her that she doesn't see it
right she doesn't know about it she
probably has that shirt in every color
right all right that does it for us
today make sure to join us tomorrow for
a new episode of et's with download
goodbye i really made myself cracked up
[Music]